on the far western coast of the
continent high atop a rocky promontory
overlooking the sunset sea sits Casterly
Rock ancestral seat of House Lannister
below it lies Lannisport one of the
great cities of Westeros a center for
trade culture and the great Lannister
fleet there are a number of gold and
silver mines in the westerland's making
it the richest region in all of Westeros
one all most productive mines lies
beneath Casterly Rock itself making
House Lannister the wealthiest of all
the noble houses this allows House
Lannister to finance many endeavours of
other noble houses even the king himself
has sought credit from Casterly Rock
from time to time we Lannister's claim
our descent from the Andal invaders and
through the female bloodline land the
clever
according to the legend LAN using only
his wits won Casterly Rock from the
noble house of Casterly during the Age
of Heroes
the Lannisters reigned as kings of the
rock for thousands of years and worked
to make it the envy of the rest of the
Seven Kingdoms our time as kings ended
however when Aegon Targaryen otherwise
known as Aegon the Conqueror arrived in
Westeros with his army the last king of
the rock King Loren Lannister joined
forces with King Mern gardener the king
of the reach together with 60,000 men
they met the Targaryen host in open
battle
history tells us that Aegon unleashed
all three of his dragons slaughtering
4,000 men and what came to be known as
the field of fire King Mern himself was
burned alive that day and house gardener
turned to ash with him seeing both the
threat and opportunity the Targaryen
represented Lauren wisely surrendered
and aided Aegon in his further conquest
of Westeros the Lannisters were thus
appointed Lords paramount of the
westerland's and wardens of the West
titles we hold to this day let us be
clear though it is neither luck nor
royal favor that makes our house
prosperous there have been times in our
history where some have thought as weak
lazy or opulent my father
Titus Lannister nearly bankrupted our
house with his poor investment and
allowed himself to be mocked openly at
court when our vassal the rains of
castamere dared to rise up against the
Lannisters they learned how dangerous it
can be to taunt a lion i Tywin Lannister
led the assault on castamere to put down
this rebellion I made an example of them
to anyone who doubts our might they even
made a quaint song about the fates of
the rains of castamere sadly there are
no rains left to hear it today the
Golden Lion of Lannister is rightly
admired and feared throughout the Seven
Kingdoms
our words are hear me roar but there are
other words that should be remembered
when crossing a lion of Casterly Rock a
Lannister always pays his debts